the Pomodoro Technique is probably one
of the most powerful techniques in all
of learning so I teach a course learning
how to learn that's actually a world's
largest massive open online course we
have something like 2 million people and
the Pomodoro Technique is the most
popular technique I hear from literally
thousands of people and I have to give
credit to the creator who was Francesco
Cirillo he developed this technique in
the early 1980s and it's so simple that
really anybody can do it
so all you have to do is turn off all
distractions so no little reviews on
your cell phone or anything like that on
your computer you want to turn off any
kind of messages that might arise set a
timer for 25 minutes and then just focus
as intently as you can for those 25
minutes now if you're like me you'll
start focusing away and you're working
away and then you look up at the timer
and two minutes have passed then my
brain goes I've only got two minutes I
can't do another 23 minutes on this
Pomodoro and I let the thought just go
right on by and I return my focus to
whatever I'm working on and when that 25
minutes is up I relax a little bit I
turn my attention to something else
now I will admit that if I really get
into the flow of what I'm doing that I I
will continue sometimes you might wonder
why that 25 minutes is the magic number
and the reality is we don't really know
there's not a lot of research on the
Pomodoro Technique
which is surprising because it's so
incredibly popular and people find it
very useful but there's an interesting
tidbit related to the Pomodoro Technique
and that is that when you even just
think about
something that you don't like very much
it activates a portion of the brain that
experiences pain and for the brain
naturally enough shifts its attention to
something else anything else like
Facebook or Twitter or something like
that and what you've just done is you
procrastinated and what the Pomodoro
Technique does when you do it you're
setting that timer you don't want to sit
there and think I am going to finish
this homework set or I'm going to work
on this problem and get it all finished
you just want to think I've got 25
minutes where I just have to work on
something no you're going to think about
what that something is what that does is
it slips in under your brain's radar it
it doesn't activate so much that pain in
your brain and then that pain in the
brain research has shown it lasts for 20
minutes so if you work for 25 minutes
you will suddenly find yourself getting
into the flow because you've gone past
that painful period so the Pomodoro
Technique is effective in many different
some very subtle ways and so I highly
recommend it
[Music]